io so che voi mi avete visto con le
maglie più antisesso della vita a questa
questa no bello a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovissimo sono fa vj
oggi siamo il sud technique useless web
site to click isto tasto please
lui ti porta su una pagina web del cazzo
davvero è il primo sito di oggi dove ci
poi questo magnifico sito fantastico
allora by please
un uomo schiaffeggiato da un anguilla
sapete qual è la cosa ancora più triste
di tutto questo ragazzi e che lo
conoscevo già e questo vi fa capire
quanta vita sociale io abbia bene
ragazzi vetrato un bellissimo assaggio
di quello che sto sito
passiamo alle cose serie please il sito
della vita
[Musica]
maghetta endless punto force cavallo
senza c'è un dominio che fa punto hors
c'è il punto it c'è il punto com e cioè
il punto hors non avevo idea mai nella
vita
se bellissimi qui non ti devo seppellire
coi soldi non è cosa da fare ma non va
bene
speri va male
[Musica]
però ragazzi questo sito era molto più
bello di facebook che anche se ci vuole
proprio vendimi qualcosa di strano
confuso va bene ma cos'è o vendi di
questa lista questo ti fa uscire fuori
delle robe su amazon nov erano parole
cetriolo elettrico vediamo i commenti di
questa cosa splendida e per caso
waterproof perché una mia amica lo
voleva sapere per diverse ragioni non
inserire questa cosa nella tua o nella
vagina di qualcun altro
va bene un altro ne voglia un altro
place di jose cela ragazzini giusto dio
che se beh qualcosa di figo lo compro
c'è un cappello con dei capelli a posto
ce l'avevo questo anche vi fa capire la
mia vita sociale come sta messa chart
provolone piccante cise provolone
piccante cheese mille dollari provolone
piccante cheese di brunello di
monticello macché ma ma che ca paparazzi
paparazzi silver screen starlet dog
costume quindi questo è un costume per
cani di una tipa con tette lo compro
ragazzi che cosa ma cosa sto vedendo il
tuo piscina di nicolas cage manca per
qualcosa
niente già c'è niente questo lo compra
questo cielo niente c'è la palla di
niente non c'è nulla dentro e per le
persone che hanno tutto occhiali a
specchio per pigri ma ho fatto vivere
senza sta roba prima cioè non capissi
carne di unicorno guarda sono più che
convinto che sarà quanto verbi di troppo
vero sto coso
vuoi vedere a ecco la prova perfetto
sono stato zittito dalla prova
fotografica che tutto questo è vero
scherzavo come schivare le navi grosse
ma cos'e 100 euro
verifichiamo antiquate recensioni può
vedere bellissima dei ragazzi vedo dove
mi porta al tipo perché sono è
infatti playmobil security check point
quanto è preoccupato quest'uomo levi
picchia 130 euro sta merda ancora ne
voglio ancora zio banana slice posso non
è proprio poco utile coste utile sempre
per pigri i cerotti al bacon altro un
altro un altro dei canapè verità hub per
fare i pisolini c'è anche una pentola di
cosa c'è una ventola di sopra ma cos'è
una ventola per l'aria la cava è
bellissimo loro no vabbè dai ditemi che
che spedisce a milano vi prego no loro
hanno bisogno hanno bisogno di sta roba
va bè ragazzi torno all'attivo su the
use le sue voglio vedere se riesce a
qualcos'altro di figo
[Risate]
non è esattamente quello che cercavo un
altra roba di aggressive password
machine duramente la mia password a lui
mi dice se la mia password sicura o meno
all'ora mette veramente la mia ho visto
canico password migliori ok ragazzi miei
per il video di oggi dire che tutto è
stato molto bello soprattutto a parte in
cui ho fatto le ricerche sul amazon e
scola è stato bello ma sicuramente
questa merda l'ho comprata lì perché non
trova altre spiegazioni però io il
formaggio la 1000 dollari un pensierino
ce lo farei è il galbanino può
accompagnare solo vabbè ragazzi spero
che questo video vi sia piaciuto non
aveva senso ma ok cosa vi fosse un
momento è un mi piace anche vari social
community 80 descrizione ed è questo che
ci perdiamo in un prossimo video difesa
ragazzi
[Musica]